celebrities might prefer to anchor their
yacht faraway in the bay of can but for
those who want to be seen the best place
to park it is just behind the palace of
the festival in yacht Road you've got
yacht starting down here and they go
down probably like half a kilometer to
pass the Palais I guess he's got a farm
out sunl Bono is trying to licence for
movies during the festival
he says renting a yacht is the most cost
effective way to set up shop and can not
only do we use it to conduct business
but we actually sleep here we've got
three different places where we can have
meetings lunches and dinners and then
obviously you know at night there's you
know cocktails and you know parties
going on as well but be warned partying
on a boat has its dangers
you have people they fall off yards
right we had to fish a few out of them
out of the water already Janette Burling
has been renting a yacht in can for the
past ten years she recently co-financed
a movie starring Halle Berry and hosting
clients on board is one way to reward
them for their money we usually use the
yards to offer our investors a little
bit of a sparkle of Hollywood because we
work with a lot of high net worth
individuals who don't just invest in
movies to get rid of their money but
also to have a little bit of fun renting
a yacht during the festival doesn't come
cheap prices often go above 100 thousand
dollars a week but it does create
unforgettable memories like last year
when Pascal went to party on a mega
yacht with director Martin Scorsese
but then Leonardo DiCaprio showed up
Martin left that boat to go on the boat
next to an even bigger yacht
and spent at Bloomberg